was it a no-brainer when it came across
to you - you know the offer came to you
to come and do this movie III when the
director came to me I just so exciting I
never thought they were hire me yes
avoid my ingress so bad and why me
doesn't know that's what we want yeah
Master Wu and they they just watch a lot
of my movies use a lot of my body
movement and hire my team to do the up
choreograph or action sequence yeah and
I I just wondering can I suitable for
this job but after I hear the depressed
day's funny
now I'm relief well I mean you had
you've had all sorts of action scenes
and all types of different fights in all
sorts of movies so it must have been a
trip to see like a LEGO version of you
doing your moves with that was that kind
of cool to see it's ten times better
than the real action they can't use a
special effect sure I I wish I can do
that I wish I can do that now
now you guys have a master and a mentor
and student relationship in this film is
there anybody in your life who's kind of
like a mentor to you
they have good question good question
probably probably
[Music]
I don't know if I can think of anyone
specific right now but I made a huge
impact on your life
I guess my my whole family my whole
family it's a very artsy family and we
really do push each other and encourage
each other and feed off each others
energy and like even my mom you know
even at this point in her life she seems
like she's taken on a new endeavor like
every year we're just a few years ago
she she got into acting and she started
writing screenplays and she started
directing a little bit he started
teaching acting on camera so it's really
inspiring
now obviously Jackie you have immense
physical skills do you think Dave would
make a great ninja did the human good
ninja yeah okay when I see the figure
yes hmm
because his body low is a good for
action oh yeah is that maybe that's your
next endeavor yeah thanks
you think you'd be a good ninja Dave if
I believe what Jackie says if he says
I'm not I'm not if he says I am I am
in the giant box bass basketball Oh new
ice colonial Chico and you you cannot be
oh and because you're not so tall and
you think this small and faster you know
even punch running and everything faster
nice now if you guys had like giant
mechs like you do in in this movie what
would they be and what would you do with
them mine would be a giant cat mech it
would it would be modeled after my two
cats Harry and Arturo and I would go
around making everyone happy if you had
a machine that you had to you had to fly
around in what would it be uh I I don't
know what which one do you like in the
movie do you like the dragon do you yeah
yeah yeah the dragon the dragon that can
save the world so here's the you wanted
to go around make everyone happy
and you want to save the world yes
different well but different but the
same I feel like that's what you're
doing with this movie as well you're
making people happy
[Laughter]
like when the earthquake um I can stop
the
the flood the helping people building
rebuild a house all kinds of things